[Music]
so the pixel buds a series the cheapest
ones right now cost 69
nice but the old retired 2020 pixel buds
before they stopped being sold were 179
dollars and i really like them i
reviewed them i thought they were nice
but they did lack active noise
cancellation and so they sort of fell a
tiny step behind the most premium best
wireless earbuds that were out and so i
mentioned this at the end of my review
this is exactly what i said maybe later
they'll do a some next-gen or a more
premium
pixel buds pro
and they'll be 279 and they'll do a
noise cancellation and a bigger battery
and it turns out well that's exactly
what we have here this is pixel buds pro
active noise cancellation larger battery
except they're only 1.99 and actually if
you're cool with any color other than
coral they're literally already on sale
on amazon for less than the price of the
last pixel buds so just to get out of
the way right off the top these have
nailed it from every single turn from
the case to the fit to the sound to the
features
you probably just close this video right
now and just pick up these
but don't do that because then you'd
ruin the watch time on this video and
then that's no fun so how about how
about i take you along and i'll show you
why these are so good so first of all
the case that these come in is basically
the same as before which is to say
underrated like so many wireless
headphones have annoyingly thick or
larger cases this is a nice compact
clean well-made case sure the white
might get a little dirty after a while
but it's got this super satisfying
magnet to open and close it is ipx2
splash resistant as a case and it has a
usbc port at the bottom but also has
wireless charging so you can pop it on
any qi wireless charger you already have
or on the back your phone if it supports
power sharing and that's all in a
package that fits in the coin pocket in
my jeans an all-around absolute win in
the case but it's what's inside the case
that we're here for and the pixel buds
pro have this new shape to them they're
mostly a matte black plastic and they
have a sort of colored cap at the end
that's either fog colored which is what
i have it's kind of a light blue or
coral a yellowish green or black so just
like any other wireless earbuds you pop
them out of the case you give them a
quarter twist to lock them into your
ears and while they don't stick out of
my ears too bad like maybe the sony
wf-1000xm4s it isn't the lowest profile
i've ever seen either it's somewhere in
between just a little bit bigger than
the last pixel buds but the main
difference for me is these don't have
the wing tips anymore the wing tips have
their upside in the downside the upside
is they would absolutely stay locked in
my ear much better i could run around
and jump and they wouldn't fall out but
the tip of it when it was in my ear for
more than about an hour or two would
create this pressure point that would
get more uncomfortable over time and i
didn't really like that too much so
these don't have that anymore which
means they're not quite as locked in my
ear
but they are more comfortable of course
earbuds are different for everybody and
when i switch to the larger earbud tips
like they really do still stay in my ear
fine for walking around normal everyday
activities and things like that but yeah
that's worth noting honestly i think
this is the right move also the buds
themselves are ipx4 rated so if you
still want to work out in them they're
sweat proof but i just probably won't so
once it's paired up and these are in
your ears there are a lot of different
features in here thanks to the pixel
buds app but i'm just going to start
with the sound you just listen to music
how do they sound
and i think these sound really really
good now i'll spare you the bunch of
descriptors and audio file terms that i
could use just to tell you basically i
really like the sound from these new 11
millimeter drivers once you get a nice
seal in your ear you can tell they're
really crisp and clear they aren't too
shrill or tinny they don't distort very
much and the noise cancellation does a
great job of getting rid of white noise
and there's basically no perceivable
bluetooth lag at all when watching
videos or gaming there's just two
slightly odd things that i noticed one
these just have a much stronger bass
than the last pixel buds i kind of noted
that as a weakness in the previous pixel
buds review like they were a little bit
weak on the bass not these the bass on
these is so much stronger and punchier
and just a more full low end that it's a
real character highlight like so hip hop
music anything with a lot of that lower
end frequency sounds really good but in
like podcasts or other genres or just
things where i don't need all that bass
i was looking for an eq to even that out
but the pixel buds app doesn't have eq
and the pixel phone also doesn't have an
eq i actually got a buds firmware update
while i was testing these and i thought
it was about to add an eq in the sound
settings but all it added was this
volume eq setting which basically just
makes things a little punchier at lower
volumes so if you do specifically want
to adjust the sound signature of these
maybe your phone has eq settings built
in some of them do maybe the app you're
using for audio has eq settings built in
some of them do but yeah pixel buds
themselves don't have eq built in yet
and neither does a pixel phone but
google has thankfully said that there is
a full five band eq coming later this
year hopefully soon but then the second
thing i noticed is these also have a
slightly lower overall volume than any
other buds i've tested in a while it's
not problematically low but i did find
myself almost always listening either
right below max volume or like two to
three notches below the max volume
because that was the comfortable
listening level usually max volume is
way too loud for more than a few seconds
of listening on most earbuds but not
here it feels like it feels like the
bottom 40 of the volume slider is
basically useless i can barely hear
anything that's that low but yeah i am
definitely impressed by how little
distortion there is and how clear and
thumpy and great it sounds at or near
max volume so that's worth noting every
pair of noise-cancelling earbuds shall
have a transparency mode at least seems
like they all should it's like an
unwritten rule of these things yeah
these are transparency mode built into
the pixel buds pro
and it's
okay it's gonna let in sound from the
microphones and pump in your ambient
noise so you can hear what's around you
but it's not the best i guess airpods
are still in a league of their own when
it comes to this but i'd rate these
transparency mode like a b minus
basically it's better than leaving them
off but it certainly still sounds
muffled and i'm hoping i'm hoping stuff
like this gets better in the future i
hope they can push firmware updates to
also improve transparency mode but the
pixel buds real advantage to me is still
definitely the software and all the
features that are built in i still love
having google assistant like a hold away
or a tap away anytime i want to ask a
question i literally just hold it down
and say
how tall is the taj mahal it's like a
superpower i can just
just start opening light shades and
turning on smart lamps and things and
just yeah assistant everywhere is great
and in the pixel buds app in the
settings you can customize what a tap
and hold on each side does so right now
i have the right side hold to trigger
the assistant but the left side hole
toggles between noise cancellation and
transparency mode pretty much every pair
of earbuds nowadays also has some sort
of touch controls on the outside for
your media these are no different it's
touch wants to play touch two times to
skip forward three times to go back the
one thing i couldn't quite get to work
as smoothly as i'd like is swiping to
change volume these
they're just not a big enough surface
for me to like reliably get a good swipe
in i kept trying to do it but this was
like the most inconsistent thing for me
basically i just end up like wobbling it
around in my ear it works sometimes but
again it's not a big surface so what i
ended up doing is i just end up reaching
in my pocket and blindly like changing
the volume on the volume rocker on the
phone in my pocket which turned out to
actually be totally fine as long as my
phone was on me so and there's a bunch
of other features too multi-device
support so these buds are paired to both
my phone and my laptop at the same time
and seamlessly switch back and forth as
advertised no problem i love that and
then they have a find my device feature
in case they get lost they have in-ear
detection to automatically play and
pause when you take them out and put
them back in and they even have this ear
tip seal check feature which analyzes
how well the microphones are actually
canceling out sound for you and if it's
not working so well it can recommend a
different size ear tip to improve the
seal it's smart the only thing missing
might be the like adaptive sound feature
which listens to your environment and
then automatically bumps up the volume
when your environment gets louder i
didn't really use that very much but i
noticed it wasn't here so that isn't in
the pixel buds pro but it's also
apparently coming other than that it's
not really missing
anything like these have every feature
that i'm used to having with earbuds and
the cherry on top as they did also with
this slightly larger body improve
battery life so you're going to get
seven hours of actual listening with
active noise cancellation on which is
far longer than i would ever listen to
earbuds that's up to you if you want to
do that 11 hours with anc off that's a
huge advantage so for 199 should you
just get these probably yeah i mean this
is easy to recommend there are some
other options out there so for around
this price you're looking at you could
definitely get air pods if you're into
that but you can also look towards if
you specifically want better sound there
are better sounding earbuds but also
something like samsung's new buds
2 or pro they're 229. i haven't gotten
the chance to hear them yet because they
just came out and samsung didn't send me
any but i imagine considering how good
the previous ones were that those might
also be really good and then also as far
as like working out in headphones or fit
in the ear i still prefer
a wing tip in the ear for like actual
workout stuff so like beats fit pro
beats studio buds those types of things
stay in my ear better so worth
considering that stuff but as far as
like everyday buds you put them in your
ear every day you take meetings on them
phone calls you walk around with them
you just have them on all the time
google assistants your super power
yeah these are great uh these are the
these are the ones i'm gonna put in my
backpack and keep around with me
everywhere i go well done google thanks
for making these please push that eq
feature i'm gonna be waiting for it
thanks for watching
catch you in the next one
peace
[Music]